foreign
[Music]
if you were alone in a room with someone
who escaped North Korea what would you
ask what does the world not know about
North Korea is there anything that you
miss about your home country what does
freedom mean to you Freedom it makes me
so sad because
[Music]
hi my name is Rebecca I'm Harry nice to
meet you nice to meet you
how old were you when you escaped and
how old are you right now I was 14 when
I was escaping now I am
22. oh okay why did you escape and what
were you risking so my mom helped South
Koreans to find their family members
while living in North Korea that's why
she was like sent to prison for two
years for this work she continued to
help someone who threatened to report
her to the police if she didn't help him
so if she stayed in North Korea my
entire family would die or end up in
prison for life that's why me and my mom
escaped North Korea she sounds like an
amazing woman yes she is wow it was
there a moment where like escaping
seemed impossible toys
foreign
people are assigned their jobs is this
still the case or how does that work in
North Korea we also have a opportunity
to choose what you wanted to do but you
have to go jail if you don't really work
so wait so it's illegal to not have a
job as an adult it's illegal that is
illegal oh I'd be arrested
how much of the outside world did you
know of before everything every like
education system in North Korea made by
the government so they taught me like
South Koreans are so poor we have to
help them and we have to fit them
because they're starving and they're
selling blood for money something like
that and they addicted drugs
these kind of things and of course like
North Koreans they don't really like
Americans I guess
every picture of Americans are soldiers
they have a gun
looks kind of aggressive and this kind
of Strat types how are people suffering
in North Korea so I think starvation is
the most serious problem you have to
find the food in the outside but there's
no system that you can earn money that's
why a lot of people die on the street
without any help how is the LGBT
community represented in North Korea in
North Korea there is no concept no terms
of gay they think that it's disease yeah
so so there's a stereotype that North
Koreans are submissive and brainwashed
what are your thoughts on that do you
think that that's true I think it's
pretty much true like I really worship
to the dictator when I first came to
South Korea I watched the video from
about the Korean war that was my first
time that I actually knowing the fact
the doors can start war
is there anything that you miss about
your home country there's a lot of
things that I miss especially I have a
sister still in North Korea that's why I
was worried about speaking in a public
place like this but unfortunately my
sister
got tortured by the government because
our Escape for four months she
continuously like rejects that she's
guilty eventually she got mental illness
from that torture and so that's why they
released her now I don't have anything
to lose so that's why I'm choosing to
speak in a public place about North
Korea but I miss her so much yeah
what do you think your life would be
like if you had never left North Korea
and South Korea they both have mandatory
military service like almost two years
but North Korea we have to serve for 10
years it starts when you are like 17.
so maybe I will be in the military
service right now if I'm in North Korea
could you tell me about any experiences
that you witnessed regarding black
people in North Korea I didn't meet any
foreigners in North Korea like any
single one when was the first time that
you met um a black person yes I remember
I met black person in 2019 yeah she was
she was a model and we took a photo
together
what does the world not know about North
Korea if you don't mind sharing they
don't really know the people actually
living in North Korea
um
whenever I got a questions from my
friends or any of the people they always
ask me about bad things about North
Korea or your bad memory they don't
really ask me about the good memories in
North Korea what are some things that
you did for fun back in North Korea I
really like to hang out with my friends
bring to mountains and rivers to swim
fish yeah I'm sure you miss them a lot
how is life in South Korea now like
versus North Korea
um so it's completely different world
like can you imagine like living without
internet or of course like Kpop or
k-drama I try to like find out the way
that I can use computers I kind of
addicted to playing games and I really
like this kind of life in South Korea do
you have a favorite video game League of
Legends OverWatch yeah
um my next question is a bit of a broad
question but what does freedom mean to
you I don't know why but every time I
think the word Freedom it makes me so
sad because it's not for everyone you
know every time I travel or every time I
eat something my little niece and nephew
this has come out to me and it's really
hard to enjoy the freedom for me it
reminds me the people who I left in
North Korea so if you had the ability to
what are some changes that you would
make to North Korea of course they need
a freedom freedom of speech freedom of
travel freedom of Education freedom is
the concept that I've never like
experienced in North Korea I didn't even
know people can actually curse their
president or you know they can protest
if there is no protest no personal
opinions on the public the government
decides everything with their own that's
why North Korea is really hard to
develop and hard to change what are your
opinions on reunification do you think
it's possible
reunification is
impossible I think impossible yeah I
don't think the North Korean regime is
going to give up but I believe one day
North Korea is gonna be open and people
can travel easily outside the North
Korea and South Koreans also can go to
North Korea but I don't think
unification is possible would you want
it to happen of course of course I want
it it happened because it's the only way
that I can like with my family and my
friends I'm just kind of realistic
person so I really hope but I don't
believe it
thank you to Jubilee for having me the
most interesting thing about North Korea
isn't dictator it's the people you can
be an ally to the North Korean people
and stand with Advocates around the
world to bring change go to with the
northscrantpeople.org Jubilee to join
the movement and sign the Allies pledge
thank you would you guys like to meet
yeah for sure
one another
yeah this is the Korean way I don't know
if you like hug or like what you
want okay thank you for sharing your
story with me how are you I like the
outfit your outfit too really thank you
and I'm so glad you're at what you are
and you're happy